هذه الشاشات في ساحه المركز الرياضي
بالقرب من الاستاد الاولمبي ومسيلاتها في
ساحات ميادين المدن كانت تعرض المباراه
بانتظام وتمثل الساحات مكانه تجمع عشاق
الساحره المستديره الا ان الاجراءات
المشدده في وقت الحرب منعت التجمعات
والانذارات الجويه وانقطاع الكهرباء حال
الدون متابعه الاوكرانيين لمباريات كاس
العالم
كمبيوتر اذا كانت هناك كهرباء ولم تكن
هناك غاره جويه الان في وقت الحرب هذه
ليست اولويه وليست هناك رغبه هؤلاء
اصدقائي ونحن نشاهد معه ونشجع ميسي لانه
يدعم اوكرانيا
الصادق كنت اشاهد كاس العالم مع اخيه
والان بسبب الحرب لا اشاهد المباريات
بالنسبه لنا هذه ذكريات جميله ولكن الان
هذا الامر غير ممكن كاس العالم كان يمثل
موسما جيدا لاصحاب المقاهي في المدينه
التي يرتادها المشجعون في مجموعات لمتابعه
المباريات مع الاصدقاء والتي كان من الصعب
ان تجد فيها موت قدم اليوم بدات مهجوره
وغاليه وقلما تجد مشاهدينا كحاله المقاهي
هذا في وسط العاصمه كيف همم
قبل الحرب باعداد كبيره لان المقهى معروف
لمحبه كره القدم الكثير من الناس كانوا
ياتون الى هنا نسبه للجوي العام الان غير
موجودين منهم من ذهب الى الحرب ومنهم من
شغلته ظروف مختلفه همم
في مدينه شابه وسكانها محبون لكره القدم
لكن الحرب غيرت المزاج العام في المدينه
وغيرت الاهتمامات وشتاء الذي داهم المدينه
مع استهداف مراكز الطاقه جعل من مشاهده
مباريات كاس العالم حلما مؤجلا كبقيه
احلام الاوكرانيه حذيفه عادل العربيه كيف